a rising ukrainian athlete being forced
to put his boxing career on hold because
of the war between russia and ukraine
now his dream is to compete on the las
vegas stage but now he's talking to
eight news now about his new focus and
if he will ever return to the ring
[Music]
it's really breaking my heart when i
hear in the stories and it's for my
family vladislav syrinko is trying to
stay positive in the midst of war as a
crisis has put his boxing career on
pause i was having a scheduled fight in
june in ukraine it's not going to happen
now i'm working for plan b i was
thinking to go and
keep my career going in the united
states the undefeated 27 year old
heavyweight from ukraine is just
starting his career with a record of 19
wins and 16 knockouts he says the
ultimate goal is in las vegas every
fighter dreaming to fight in a big
arenas
in las vegas like mgm grand in new york
i think it's the dreams of every fight
you know my dream as well but the war
between russia and his home country of
ukraine he says has changed that for now
because his priority is his loved ones i
was talking to my arm she is leaving not
far away from kiev like 20 miles away
it's a small airport not far away from
her house and four o'clock in the
morning they wake up because
russian army will start bombing the
airport sorenko tells us war is never a
solution because so many lives are
destroyed he only hopes his family can
survive so they can continue to be his
biggest fans outside the ring he was
living a good life you were safe and
next morning you just wake up and you
get in bombs you just must leave your
house and go somewhere it's really
terrible christian casa is live local
now